[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir tous les coups sont permis aux
dames et messieurs
sauf dans les galeries
de mettre le feu pour l'arrivée des
combattants
on commence par le challenger et
entraîne cette chaussure 7 24 heures sur
24 depuis six mois
il a même perdu 15 kilos pour le combat
mais
5 ce mois-ci un goal de match et perdre
il est gonflé à bloc il ne pas tenir
depuis trois jours c'est du jamais vu
n'oubliez jamais qu'avec atteint ça
castagne
mesdames et messieurs voici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'heure de jeu
de tennis
je ne sais pas le boucher cacher de
match sert défait 0 victoire même temps
0 combat c'est l'empereur de la barca
est pensionnaire ce soir ce sera sa
boîte il a du mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant je vous demande
d'accueillir larry google
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
messieurs bienvenue vous avez bien en
forme bien entraînés très bien et bien
messieurs ça va être l'heure du combat
donc je vais vous demander de vous
rapprocher l'un de l'autre au milieu du
ring
s'il vous plaît allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par la combinaison qu'on a dit ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
copé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]